Michael you said yesterday that original
sin started with Adam eating the Apple
but why does Eve get off the hook she
ate at first right she does and this
confounds some people when they read the
Epistles of Saint Paul because Paul says
that in Adam all man sinned
you say why Adam
Eve was the one who took the first bite
and I've always assumed this is the case
because man is the head of woman is
Christ as the head of the church and so
if Adam is the head of his household his
identic paradisical household then he
Bears greater responsibility you've got
duped by the serpent
and
Adam gave in to Eve our first our first
father